في فيديو متداول على المنصات سعوديا بشكل
كبير اليومين الماضيين والفيديو بيظهر
تاثره فرح اب بتخرج ابنته
يب وجهي لا تخافي من دنيتي عن كل الماضي
يخوفك لا تخافي
لو الليالي والزمان يتحدات
لا يضيق
كله الظروف اللي تشوفين تفداك نامي على
راحتي يدي لا تبالي
يبين ولا يطلع اقساط وانا معك عمري
الفيديو اتضح انه من تخريج جامعه الملك
خالد في ابها وكان الخميس الماضي وحصد
الكثير الكثير من المشاهدات من الناس اللي
تاثرت بتاثر الوالد لكن التاثر تضاعف بشكل
اكبر بكثير لما اتضحت القصه الحقيقيه
الخريجه واسمها سميره هي ابنه الرجل في
الفيديو بالتبني فهو كان بيشتغل في مستشفى
ولاحظ انه تسعه اشهر والطفله موجوده فتعلق
فيها فاخذها رغم انه عنده ثمانيه ابناء
وبنات ومنهم من انهم في سنها اصلا ورضعت
في منزله وصارت من ابنائه واخبرته وصلوا
لسميره ووالدها وحكوا قصتهم
[موسيقى]
سميره ولدت عام 2001 واخذناه وعمرها
تقريبا تسعه شهور كانت تهز السرير تهز
السرير تهز السرير تبكي
احتملت اني
صرت اخذها من فتره فتره اطلعها بره وادور
باكلها الى ان تعلقت وتعلقت بي ثم اراد
الله سبحانه وتعالى ان تاتينا
[موسيقى]
طبعا
رضعناها وكان اصغر اولادي في سنها سبب
بكائي انا والله ما العب ما ولام على هذا
شفت ثمره تعبنا وجهدنا يمشي امامنا في
الميدان
الحمد لله الذي رزقني هذه العائله عشت
معاهم 21 سنه
عمرهم ما فرقوا بيني وبين اخواني اخواتي
[موسيقى]